hey I'm William Jackson Harper and
you're at BuzzFeed and I'm gonna answer
some of your burning questions huh all
right how did you react when the
internet was freaking out over shirtless
Chiti remember when I was doing but I
wasn't watching in real time and my
buddy texted me and was just like yo
Twitter wants Chi to get naked I was
just like oh well that's Pleasant that's
good you know like I guess we got away
with it you know I was perfectly happy
being objectified I never get to be that
guy what was it like working with Lisa
Kudrow how did you react when he found
out she was cast as Patti
uh oops I just straight pooped myself
you know honestly it's like looking
evidence in the episode spoiler alert
cheating it has a complete fangirl
moment that was not acting that was just
me getting to geek out over Lisa Kudrow
lost my mind how long did you know how
the show was going to end at the
beginning of season 4 they sort of
walked us through how this is all gonna
play out I think they trusted us with
the state-secrets after the first season
we you know proved ourselves capable to
keep him up keeping her mouth shut and
so I have known for the for the for the
year who was the most exciting guest
star for you to work with you know I
think personally it's like any we've had
my Rudolph Lisa Kudrow we've had Adam
Scott but I think maybe one of the best
was a top ney who is actually one of the
philosophers that consults on our show
and trying to understand these concepts
or is so beyond me that anyone is that
big of a brain is incredibly exciting to
be around so spike it was a guest star
you wish would have been on the show no
I mean like we got the best of the best
I mean it's kind of hard to be like well
I really wish we had I mean that you
know I don't want to you know look a
gift horse in the mouth
nobody grape spike do you have a
favorite good place Easter Egg or
recurring gag you know I think it's got
to be Meghan am Rams puns on the stores
they change every season every couple of
episodes it's ridiculous and she's a
she's a machine so that's you know
that's that's the number one thing
there's not even a close second what's
your favorite behind scenes memory from
filming honestly like me and Ted Danson
have a whole bunch of dance parties
randomly we would just like just goof
off every year that happened and it
happened often so is there a good place
group chat there is Spike given that
this video will air after the finale can
you give us a completely no context
spoiler no go watch the damn show son
spike
when did you realize Eleanor and GD
would be in-game I you know I never
really knew I feel like it's weak and we
learn on the same journey that the
audience went on so which is kind of
cool I think that feels like life do you
believe in soulmates
uh no not really I think that it's
something that is uh the develop you
find a person that you want to commit to
and it's sort of an active choice and
then you do the work and you know as
explained in the show something I had
thought about him when he showed up in a
script I was like oh okay some smart
people agree with me so there we go
spike what do you think is the funniest
joke of all time from the good place
there is one line that many said that
broke all of us repeatedly which was
just like was it you know what Shawn you
used to be cool with your change
and which none of us could hear him say
that line and keep a straight face
I think there was one take that we were
all in that was usable and that's the
only one that wound up in the show
because no one held it together for the
whole time knowing what you know now
would you rather be in Michaels bad
place the medium place or the good place
I think the the good place neighborhood
that Michael designed is torture for us
is probably the best place that we've
all been I think this is because it's
the same before it's like a forge
relationships which were really
meaningful and I feel like you know
pleasure devoid of someone to share it
with is kind of empty so I think that
that that's the best that's the best
place to be what do you think of Darcy's
Chiti in the Janet's episode did you
give her any pointers I think Darcy's GD
is better than my GT and I gave her some
pointers but I mean I remember watching
her and being like well damn she kind of
read those lines better than I would
have read them and and I just she's also
just so likable I mean like you know
so I I didn't really have a whole lot I
mean she did listen to my voice a bunch
which you know you know bless her for
that thanks for your burning questions
this has been so much fun
be sure to wash a good place
[Music]